jacob rees-mogg is one of the best-known
and most controversial figures in this
government a hard-line brexiteer his
views often divide opinion and he always
speaks his mind he's now a cabinet
minister and so has unique access to
government decisions a government under
pressure of partygate scandal and a cost
of living crisis and with a big
announcement from the chancellor today
i've spoke to him about what that means
for the country but also about what
drives him in politics
jacob rees-mogg thanks so much for
talking to me today i really appreciate
it and i've got lots to talk about
there's lots going on in the news
about
the sue gray report the cost of living
but first i wanted to talk a little bit
about you
and your political outlook
um and there's lots of things about you
viewers might not know that you were a
hugely or are a hugely successful
investment banker before you came into
politics uh you married in 12th you and
your
wife helena have six children you're a
devout roman catholic
yours is a very fortunate and fulfilled
life
so why
politics um
a number of reasons one is that if you
have been very fortunate in life
you might feel that you've got a duty to
do something about it if you've got the
opportunity to do it so that's the sort
of pious reason
but there's then the fact that it is
enormously and captivatingly
interesting so i enjoy doing it but i
also think i have an element of duty to
do it and just in terms of your
political career you are in cabinet
you're one of the most well-known faces
actually i would argue of the
conservative party often it's quite
difficult for politicians to get cut
through but you do have cut through
um but you've also become
a
touch paper a bit if you don't mind me
saying at times and you're you're a
divisive politician sometimes that lots
of people really really like you uh but
you also come in for quite a lot of
criticism that does it surprise you and
why do you why do you think that is
oh well i think if you're in politics
you must expect that people will
disagree with you and will disagree with
you strongly
on important issues so
if you take brexit brexit was very
divisive for the country and people who
were in favor of it really wanted to get
our independence back felt that was
fundamentally important people on the
other side of the argument felt in some
cases that something they had worked for
their whole political careers was being
removed and were very upset about that
so
if you're
in politics surely you want to put
forward your views you want to put them
forward as clearly as possible
and then you're going to find people
disagree with you
you could be a lib dem and say whatever
people want here and then you hope that
nobody will either like you or dislike
you that doesn't seem to be a lot of
point in that and before i get on to
what type of conservative you are just
just to finish off in this idea of the
divisiveness which
you acknowledge
does it does it bother you i mean i saw
that you were heckled at a university uh
during brexit i think your family were
bothered while they were with you
do you just see that as the ugly
underbelly of politics or do you
actually think that it's a kind of
corrosive aspect of public life does it
upset you when you personally experience
things like that no because i'm a great
believer in freedom of speech right and
i think
nobody made me go into public life your
opening question was why did i do it i
have decided to go into public life
therefore people are entitled to
disagree with me and they're entitled to
disagree with me
forcefully and they are entitled to
wave banners at me
as long as it isn't physical
intimidation
i think it is perfectly legitimate for
politicians to face
argument about what they believe in um
steve bray is entitled to stand in the
middle of the road and shout nonsense
all day long because that's what he
believes in and that's freedom of speech
and i do worry actually that we don't
protect freedom of speech as much as we
ought to in this country and what type
of conservative are you
what type of conservative am i
well i believe in
freedom of the individual starting point
and
most things flow from that that i
believe that it's people's own money not
the government's money and therefore
people should be entitled to keep their
own money as far as possible low tax
they're taxed that they should make
decisions about their own lives with as
little interference
from the state as is
practical
a small stage yes would you like to see
a more closer link between
the church and the state between
politics and the church or do you think
that these things should
remain separate
i think we've got it about right in this
country
i'm not an anglican but i like the fact
that the anglican church is the
established church it maintains
a place for god
within our civic society so remembrance
sunday the
anglican church leads it um there will
be the service for
70 years of the queen's reign the
platinum jubilee that will be led by the
anglican church
i think the
position of the archbishop of canterbury
is a very important one and i this may
surprise you i haven't been a great
admirer of the archbishops i think he is
a good and holy man even when he makes
political interventions because he gets
very criticized by many of your
colleagues for when he does that i i
think you can admire and respect people
even when they say things that you would
rather they didn't say so this doesn't
mean i adopt all his political views it
may mean i disagree strongly with them
but i think he is
um a force for good in society and i
think he's a genuinely holy man actually
do you think he should be allowed to say
it though i believe in freedom of speech
of course he should be able to
the reason i ask is that many of your
colleagues i i there was a recent
example
and a number of your colleagues i think
you might have been critical about the
prime minister around the partygate
issue i think that might have been i
can't quite remember a number of your
colleagues were maybe in the borders it
was the border policy yeah forgive me
the border policy he was very critical
of what wasn't he
and a lot of your colleagues
said that this was inappropriate
and actually there's a bit of a pylon
towards the archbishop you don't agree
with being silenced in that way
he must make his own statements um and
must be free to say what he wants i
didn't agree with him but i went to
the cardinal archbishop westminster
vincent nichols um homily at the red
mass which is the master begin the legal
yeah
and he stood in the an portfolio
magnificent sermon he gave he said look
you're very important judges and you'll
judge all these important cases
but don't forget
there's a higher judge who will judge
you one of these days
and so if i like it when clerics say
things that make people sit up and think
when i agree with them
i shouldn't be too
squeamish when they say things that make
people sit up and think that i don't
agree with that's reasonable and and
jacob just on another
sort of political personal issue just
one more thing on this roe versus wade i
was interested in this about what you
might have felt about this it was the
landmark legislation that legalized
abortion across it wasn't legislation
sorry to be scientific it was a case
that's right it was a case that the
supreme court ruled on but my pedentry
is very important because that wasn't
democratically decided and that seems to
me to have been
the the source of all the trouble
whereas this country decided it
demonstrates i'm sorry sorry no no
that's that's absolutely
completely fine um but you wouldn't want
to ban abortion um
there's no prospect of parliament voting
to ban abortion but i think the numbers
are just the saddest aspect of modern
british life
the saddest the did
200 000 babies that aren't born
this is this is so sad desperate this
loss of life that would otherwise be
created i think is desperately sad
now we were just talking you are a small
state low tax conservative today a 37
billion pound package just announced by
the chancellor
is it your view that the public
particularly full and covered are now
too reliant on the government and the
state to solve problems that this pack
is just when does it stop
well
this is in a way a continuation of the
kobit problem
i was very strongly in support of the
fairly scheme and other schemes like
that because the government is there
when everything else is collapsing
and if the government hadn't provided
fellow hadn't provided loans to
businesses but we would have had no
economy to come back to when things
reopened
and that would have been even more
inflationary than what we've currently
got currently the disruption to supply
chains
made worse by war in ukraine made worse
um
by the rise in fuel prices
is an aftershock
of covid
very much like the aftershocks you get
with an earthquake
and the government
cannot leave people completely unable to
pay their fuel bills
so the state has a role
david davis and john redwood just in the
chamber have warned already about
inflationary risks about today's
measures do you see their concerns do
you share them well i see their concerns
and as i say i think this is a bouncing
act
that it would be foolish of me to
pretend it's easy to to get right
and
on another let's just get through the
measures that he just now
he's also announced his temporary level
on the profits of oil and gas companies
at a rate of 25
all but in name a windfall tax you've
been openly against a windfall tax
haven't you well um importantly it is
not retrospective
retrospective taxation
is to my mind entirely improper that
people must be taxed on what they know
is going to come
so that's an important change but if you
you don't sound like you it's not you
it's collective responsibility i support
government you support government policy
but have you changed your mind because
you were against it but this is what i
said to you earlier i think collective
responsibility is fundamentally
important and that ministers
are
right to argue for what they believe
in private yes and then accept the
conclusion when it comes out
the
contextualization i'm trying to give is
that these are not easy decisions it is
a balance
it is really important to protect people
and help people who would simply have no
money
if the fuel price increase went up and
they received no help
and pensioners as well and and
the welfare state does have an
obligation to look after people in that
position how you then pay for it well
is one tax better than another tax well
i was actually uh well actually let's
come to that then because um i had
something that i i wanted to ask you
about that which is um
as a wealthier person in society as i am
as well do you think that we have
wealthier people a moral duty to help
people that are less well-off whether
that's through taxation so wealthier
people pay more or through philanthropy
of course i do i mean this to go back to
the discussion we're having on religion
this is one of the fundamental tenets of
of christianity
expand
well
you you um should love thy neighbors
myself um
the the parable of the good samaritan um
who is my neighbor well everybody is my
neighbor so there there is a
responsibility to help others in society
does it alarm you i was looking today uh
2 million people in the uk need to use
food banks one in five people according
to yougov this morning now say they're
struggling to or unable to make ends
meet that's a ten percent rise on last
year and half of households say their
financial situation has deteriorated in
the last year alone it's quite worrying
isn't it it is very worrying inflation
is terribly worrying because inflation
hits the least well off most
that's why the chancellor's been doing
what he has been doing today it's why
the support packages are very important
and the
difficulty
with our current welfare system is that
some benefits
are operated retrospectively so if you
have a year of inflation
you get the operating
in the
um
april of the following year on the
september figure
now over a multi-year period that
balance is
out but in an individual year when
inflation is running at a rapid rate
that is really difficult for people
which is why the chancellor
that's right it's bringing forward a
help that otherwise might say
so you would even though you sort of
philosophically ideologically
might not be in favor of increased
taxation increase spending to support
people at this moment in time because of
inflationary pressure you're okay with
it basically well it also depends on
what you mean by increased expenditure
because how are you judging this
expenditure well
but you're bringing i mean bringing
forward benefits it's just moving the
money forward while the inflation's
higher if inflation is running at 10
and you have um
gdp growth which is always real terms
growth of zero the government still has
expenditures of central gdp if it
remained flat
would be reduced proportionately
so
in an inflationary time
there is money that is available in a
strange way that wouldn't otherwise be
very available whilst keeping
expenditure level proportionate to gdp
you then have to ask yourself the
question as does that expenditure risk
becoming more inflationary itself
i think saying that supporting the least
well-off
is inflationary is a mistake i think you
may need to look at other areas of
expenditure but you surely want to help
those who who are absolutely squeezed
first by inflation the other big news
this week was sue gray's report you said
in march concerns over partygate in
downing street were fluff and
fundamentally trivial that was in march
do you still think that having read the
report
what we've been discussing we have been
discussing inflation the fact that some
people may not be able to
um make ends meet
we haven't discussed ukraine but the
whole security of the western world has
been at risk over the last
few months
and i i think the um
intellectual energy spent on partygate
has been completely disproportionate but
do you but having read the report do you
still think it's trivial
what happened well i'm afraid i'm going
to say the same to you
because you had an incident where you
were at a party
and you apologized for it
to resign through i offered my
resignation as well and i sent you a
message saying i hope it didn't no you
wouldn't you know kind of because i
thought i thought the reaction to you
was disproportionately i didn't think it
was true it wasn't true i'm not asking
you if you thought i'm contributing i am
consistent in my view i think the
reaction to you was disproportionate i
think the reaction over particular is
disproportionate and i think the
reaction to secure stamina is
disproportionate um that so many
really important things are going on
uh that we need to get on with um the
these
prime minister
um got a fine for
what seemed to be one of the least
things that went on
uh in downing street some of them that
are in the report didn't even go on in
downing street they were in the cabinet
office which
is not where the prime minister is the
events the prime minister was at were
daytime events
it it seems to me
too much has been made of it when so
many other important things are going on
and the prime minister has apologized
but jacob just just one other follow-up
on this if you don't mind in that report
there were reports of staff vomiting
after too much alcohol a drunken
altercation
red wine on the walls rudeness to
security staff
i mean
well can you imagine behaving like that
at work the
um
as i understand it the the um
vomiting and the fight were a party in
the cabinet office which is a set which
is a it's just about it more broadly not
i'm not asking you directly about the
prime minister but that's but that's
quite that's quite important because it
all relates to the problems so to make
it clear which i think has been that
what sounds to have been the worst
incident
was actually not in downing street at
all well there was there was another one
in downtown
i'm just asking you more broadly it must
mortify you i mean do you not find that
morally abhorrent i think it's
absolutely disgraceful being rude to um
the people who are providing essential
services in a government building
but we know that only two elected
politicians were fined out of the
83 and it was neither of the two elected
politicians who were rude to the staff
you know so
again this is not a culture encouraged
by the prime minister prime minister
would never be rude to people uh who
were working for him just finally 74
percent of the public think the prime
minister knowingly lied that that's a
problem for like whatever the rights and
wrongs that that is a problem for him
isn't it
well i don't think that's a fair
reflection i think the prime minister
said what he believed to be the case now
it is really important to remember
that it is deliberately mislead
parliament we all make mistakes
you know that sometimes you misread a
figure when you're speaking in
parliament and you are allowed to and i
have
put corrections
um on the record if one has got a
decimal point in the wrong place or um
read a figure on the next line of one's
briefing
that
the prime minister
did not believe that the rules had been
broken and when you look through
sue grey's report that seems to me to be
perfectly reasonable the events he was
at
were ones that when he was there were
within the rules
other than other than the one uh in in
the cabinet office which
um
seems to me one where a reasonable
person could come to the conclusion that
it was um a perfectly
proper event and jacob reese just wanna
see so you'll say just to be clear you
just said you're saying if the prime
minister middle did mislead parliament
on this stage he didn't he didn't that's
right that's right that's right and
that's crucial that's absolutely
fundamental so you think he might have
misled parliament inadvertently because
he didn't have the information he said
no rules were broken and we now know
that rules were broken clearly so you
think he'll be exonerated by the
privileges committee well the privileged
committee um is is an independent
committee it wouldn't be right for me to
pre-judge it
that may even be breach privilege itself
so i bet i'll get into that thank you
very much my pleasure